الحرب الهجينة على المنشطات هذه هي
الكلمات التي يستخدمها المسؤولون الغربيون
لوصف الوضع في الوقت الحالي في
محطة الطاقة النووية الزابارية في
أوكرانيا ، وهي أكبر
مجمع نووي في كل أوروبا الآن
ادعى فلاديمير بوتين أن الجيش الأوكراني
كان يقصف بنفسه  مصنع
في وسط بلدهم
ولكن لا توجد صور أقمار صناعية ، فقد لا
يفاجئك أن تظهر أنه لا توجد
علامات على قصف منهجي
في كل هذا حيث يقول كبار مسؤولي الدفاع في الولايات المتحدة
أو مسؤول دفاعي كبير في الولايات المتحدة
إن روسيا أظهرت
تجاهلاً تامًا للمصنع.
وصفها الأمن بأنه ذروة
عدم المسؤولية في الأسابيع القليلة الماضية ،
استخدمت القوات الروسية
موقعًا أو مواقع قريبة جدًا إن
لم تكن في الداخل ، ثم الرقبة جدًا
بجوار محطة الطاقة النووية لقصف
عبر النهر باستخدام الصواريخ أه
قصف بلدة  نيكوبول قتلوا 13
شخصًا هناك على الرغم من أنني كنت في قرية
قبل يومين مما أسفر عن
مقتل أشخاص هناك
الناس ودمروا بعض القرى
والمنازل ليست قرى كاملة معذرة أه
في عدد من المناطق
التي تقع في مرمى هذه
القذائف الروسية ادعى الروس
أن الأوكرانيين كانوا يرتدونها
ولكن الآن هذه الصور الأخيرة للأقمار الصناعية
تشير بوضوح شديد إلى حد ما
يشير تحليل ذلك إلى أنه لم
تكن هناك زيادة كبيرة في
الأضرار التي لحقت
بالمواقع الروسية والمواقع التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا حول محطة الطاقة النووية تلك
لمدة شهر بحيث
يعطي الكذبة المتأخرة للبيان الأخير
الصادر عن الرئيس الروسي والذي
وفقًا لـ  قرأ الكرملين
المكالمة الهاتفية مع
الرئيس الفرنسي إيمانويل ماكرون
التي استخدم فيها أه فلاديمير بوتين مصطلح
القصف المنهجي في
الهجمات الممنهجة التي تقوم بها
أوكرانيا بحيث ثبت عدم
صحتها لكنها في الخطوط الأمامية أمر
بالغ الأهمية.  موقع ضعيف
وفوق ذلك ماكرون هو أحدث
شخص يلفت الانتباه إلى هذا هناك قلق عميق
حول الخطط الروسية
المحتملة لإعادة توجيه الكهرباء من
الشبكة الأوكرانية إلى شبكة تسيطر عليها
روسيا محفوفة
بالمشكلات الفنية التي قد تتسبب أيضًا في حدوث كارثة.